[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طيب يعطيكم العافيه
الفصل الماضي مع ضغط الشغل
لقيت حالي في وضع شويه صعب كانت الساعه
2:00 بالليل
وكان في عندي امتحانين لليوم اللي بعده
لازم الصباح اكون سلمت الامتحانات وطبعت
الاسئله وكان في عندي زي توقف بتدفق
الافكار مش قادر اطلع بافكار لاسئله
قد ما حاولت الاسئله مش قاعده بتطلع معي
الان الواحد لما يكون في وضع ضعف في نقطه
ضعف دائما الشيطان بيجي وبيوسوس له وانا
شيطاني وقتها اجاني وقال لي ليش ما
تستخدمش اذا الطلاب بيستخدموه عشان
يجاوبوا على الاسئله اللي انت بتكتبها انت
كمان ممكن تستخدم عشان يعطيك اسئله تعطيها
للطلاب الان اذا
كنت متابع اذا ما كنت سامع المفروض انه
زميلنا من المحاضره اللي قبل اعطاك فكره
على ايش ممكن يسوي في مجال السينما ممكن
تتخيل نفس الاشي على الاشياء الثانيه
بالنسبه الي كشخص في مجال الحاسوب
ممكن اني انا اعمل
نقاش مع تشات عن كود
اوريه كود هو ما عمره شافه من قبل واساله
انه يشرح لي هذا الكود ممكن اتامر عليه
واقول له اشرح لي اياه باختصار اشرح لي
اياه بالتفصيل اشرح لي اياه بشكل هزني
بشكل كوميدي او غيره بشكل عام عنده قدره
قويه جدا انه يجري معي هذا الحوار فمثلا
هنا شرحوا بشكل جيد مع اني انا حاطين له
خطا بهذا الكود
فما اثر على قدرته انه يشرح ايش هذا
البرنامج بسوي
وبعد ما شرح لي اياه سالته وقلت له طيب في
خطا في هذا البرنامج قال نعم اه في خطا في
هذا البرنامج حدد لي اياه وحكى وين الخطا
وكيف ممكن اني انا اصلحه
الان هذا شيء غير مسبوق بالنسبه لنا احنا
في علوم الحاسوب
انه يكون قادر انه يدير هذا الحوار عن كود
هو ما شافه قبل شيء غير مسبوق
وممكن انك تقيس هذا على جميع المجالات
الثانيه وتعرف قديش
بمثل ذروه الذكاء الاصطناعي والتطبيقاته
في المجالات اللغويه المهم انه اذا انت
جديد على كمان تعرف انه قدرته على اجراء
الحوار حول هذا الكود ما كان نابع من
فهمه لهذا الكود فهو مع انه شرحه بشكل جيد
هذا مش معناته انه هو فاهمه هو كل اللي
صار انه هو ولد بشكل جيد كلمات احتماليه
انها تكون هي الكلمات اللي انا ببحث عنها
بناء على الكود اللي انا كتبته والسؤال
انا كتبته عاليه بناء على ايش بناء على
امثله كثيره لكود ولاسئله ثانيه هو كان
شايفها قبل فالان الفكره انه هو صحيح
بيقدر انه يدير حوار بشكل ممتاز جدا بيقدر
يجاوب اسئله معقده جدا ولكن في نفس الوقت
ما بيقدر يجاوب اسئله جدا بسيطه بالنسبه
لنا احنا لانه قدرته ما لها علاقه
بالتحليل المنطقي وانما قدرته بناء على
الامثله اللي هو شافها قبل فسؤال بسيط جدا
زي ايهما اثقل كيلو الحديد ولا كيلو القطن
بيفشل فيه يعني بشكل سريع بقول لك المفروض
انه يقول لك كيلو من اي ماده هي نفس الاشي
بس هو بحكي لك لا كيلو الحديد اثقل من
كيلو القطن
لانه هو ما بيحلل تحليل منطقي وانما بناء
على ايش شاف امثله قبل فلو اخذنا الاشي
هذا شوي زياده ووديناه على اشي هو مش
متدرب عليه كثير زي مثلا للغاز
الشعبيه اللي عنا بالاردن فتتوقع انه لانه
ما شاف زيها كثير انه كمان ما يقدر يجاوبك
بشكل كويس فلو سالته سؤال زي هذا اللي كان
يسالني اياه جدي زمان وانا صغير خيار اسمه
الله لا يهديك على اسمه ايش اسمه يعني ما
في اي شيء في السؤال لانه السؤال بقول لك
خيار اسمه ثاني اسمه خيار بس هو شو بيقول
بقول لا يوجد خيار يسمى الله لا يهديك وهو
اسم غير لائق ومهين عند استخدام ولا اي
شخص او كان اخر يرجى تجنب استخدام الالفاظ
المسيئه
التي قد تثير الاخرين والحرص على استخدام
اسماء لائقه المهم
هذا اللي ما بيعرف يجاوب اسئله بسيطه زي
هاي وبنفس الوقت بيقدر يجاوب اسئله صعبه
جدا
الشيطان حكى لي استخدمه بركي يساعدك بانك
انت تكتب امتحان فجربت حظي معه طلبت منه
سؤال للامتحان الاول وما كان ما كان حظ
جيد اعطاني سؤال مش بالمستوى اللي انا بدي
اياه طلبت منه مره ثانيه عدلت من وصف بركي
انه اعطاني السؤال زي ما انا بدي اياه ما
اعطاني اياه بالشكل اللي بدي اياه لقيت
حالي داخل معه بحوار على انه ايش معنى صعب
ايش معنى سهل سهل لمين صعب لمين لقيت حالي
بضيع وقتي تركته ورحت على الامتحان الثاني
بركي انه قدر انه يعطيني شيء افضل
هناك نفس الاشي مخيب للامال اقترح علي
سؤال مش زي ما انا بدي اياه
وجاوبه غلط فدخلت معه كمان بنقاش انه ليش
هو غلط
ليش كيف لازم يكون الجواب لقيت حالي برضو
كمان بضيع وقتي فتركته وبدات اشتغل على
الامتحان لحالي الان اللي صار معي في
الايام اللي بعدها هو انه ذهني انشغل
بسؤال انه صحيح تشاد حاليا
مش قاعد بيجاوب كثير من الاسئله السهله
بشكل كويس وما قدر يفيدني كثير الان فيني
انا اكتب امتحان كان مخيب للامال لكن
المتوقع المتوقع انه خلال الايام الجايه
او السنوات الجايه انه راح يكون قدرته
اعلى بكثير من قدرته الحاليه
متوقع جدا انه يستطيع انه يكتب اسئله
امتحانات ممتازه انه يستطيع يجاوب على
اسئله امتحانات انه يطلع على حلول طلاب
ويطلع الاخطاء اللي فيها يعطي تغذيه راجعه
للطلاب انه يعمل تلخيصات لمقالات تلخيصات
لدروس تيتو من من هذا النوع فالان اذا كان
خلال الفتره القادمه صار ممتاز جدا بكل
هاي الاشياء اللي انا فعليا بتاخذ اغلب
وقتي كمدرس انا دورك مدرس ايش صار
طبعا مباشره انا اللي بيجي الرد لا انا
كمدرس مش فقط ناقل للمعلومه انا مربي
والتربيه قبل التعليم طبعا هذا الرد
لمباشره انا يعني امكانيه الدفاع اللي
عندي راح تقول طبعا انا مش فقط ناقل
للمعلومه
ولكن بالمقابل ممكن اجي اقول انه اه طيب
فممكن استبدالك بتشات لمجال نقل المعلومه
وبمربي يربي
الان هذا سؤال مرعب بالنسبه لي انا كمدرس
انه اكون على المحك انه فعليا انا ممكن
استبدالي
او كاونتلر او مربي زائد
لانه بحط قيمه الشيء اللي انا بعمله على
المحك الان سؤال الاستبدال انه
الذكاء الاصطناعي يستبدل وظيفه ما سؤال من
اربعين خمسين سنه دائما مطروح اللي انا
كنت بتامله انه انا وظيفتي مختلفه عن هذيك
الوظائف هذيك وظائف فيها شيء ميكانيكي
فيها شيء ممكن انك انت تعمله بخطوات فلذلك
ممكن انه الماكينه انها تستبدلك اما انا
وظيفتي يعني اعظم واسمى من ذلك صعب انه
ذكاء اصطناعي انه يعملها الان في شيء خطر
على بالي وقتها خلاني شويه احس انه الخطر
مش كبير مقارنه
واللي هي كالتالي انه خلال الفتره الماضيه
كان في انفجار كبير في الكورسات
للتعليم عن بعد
جودتها عاليه ومن مدرسين ممتازين جدا ولكن
هي عن بعد في نفس الوقت في مقاومه كبيره
من كثير من الطلاب ومن كثير من الاهالي
للتعلم عن بعد يعني ايش هم ما بدهم تدريس
عن قرب فاذا كان في مقاومه انك تكون بعيد
عن المدرس فمن باب اولى يكون في مقاومه
كمان انه يستغني تماما الانسان على المدرس
ويستبدله باله هل هذا شيء مطمئن لكن
السؤال هو ليش هل
هناك شيء خاص فيه كمدرس انسان غير موجود
في الاله
بحيث انه التعليم عن بعد بصير اسوا او اذا
انا بطل في انسان في المجال بصير اسوا
هذا السؤال اللي انا كنت بفكر فيه
في طالب سالني سؤال قال لي دكتور كيف ممكن
ياثر تشات جي بي تي الان على مجال البرمجه
وانا بتناقش معه وسالته سؤالك هذا انت
سالته
قال لي اه سالته وجاوبك قال لي جاوبني
جواب ممتاز كمان بس انا حابب اعرف رايك
انت
فكان من جوابه مبين انه هو ما بدور فقط عن
معلومه بس بدور على ثنائي معلومه زائد
انسان معين هو اللي يحكي هاي المعلومه كان
بدور على هذا الاشي
في
جامعه جامعه معروفه صار فيها حادث اطلاق
نار في جامعه جنبها
الاداريين اللي في الجامعه ارسلوا رساله
للطلاب رساله مواساه زائد توعيه بخصوص
حادث اطلاق النار اللي كتب الرساله كتبها
باستخدام الان لما عرفوا الطلاب انه هاي
الرساله كاتبها يعني موظف ما كتبها بايده
صارت ضجه كبيره وصارت لجان تحقيق وصار في
استقالات الان الغضب ما كان من الطلاب ان
على المحتوى تاع الرساله لانه والله ما
كان محتوى جيد او كان محتوى خطا الغضب كان
من انه اللي يولد المحتوى ما كان انسان
وانما كان اله
يعني يبدو انه هذا الثنائي تاع انه في
محتوى والمحتوى صادر عن انسان مؤثر بشكل
ما وهذا بخليني اشعر شويه بالارتياح انه
في ميزه لكوني انسان يعني يبدو انه ما
مندور دائما فقط عن معلومه ولا انما كمان
معلومه وفي معها انسان
الله سبحانه وتعالى بيقول ولو جعلناه ملكا
لجعلناه رجلا ولا لبسنا عليهم ما يلبسون
يعني الرسول المعلم مقصود منه ان يكون
انسان لانه بعلم ناس ولو ما كان انسان
يعني لو كان ملك
لجعلناه يظهر وكانه رجل
لانه مره ثانيه يبدو انه هذه الثنائيه بين
كون المعلومه صادره من انسان في لها اثر
لانه التعلم هو مش بس معلومه وانما في شيء
له علاقه بتجسيد معنى الشيء اللي انت
بتتعلمه
فانا كمدرس للبرمجه بجسد معنا انك انت
تكون مبرمج مسؤول او مبرمج دائم التعلم او
مبرمج حذر او غير ذلك الان هاي الاشياء
كلها الالي ممكن تحكيها للمتعلم وتقول له
هكذا يمكن ان تكون مبرمج حذر هكذا يمكن ان
تكون مبرمج مسؤول هذه الخطوات التي يجب ان
تتبعها الان هذا مختلف تماما عن لما انا
اعيش مع الطالب في دائره من انه هو يكون
معي وانا بشوف السؤال بقسمه الاجزاء بعدين
كل جزء ببرمجه بهيئه معينه وبكيفيه معينه
بطرح اسئله بشكل معين عن صحه سؤالي وبعدين
كيف بصححه الان هذه الدائره لما يعيشها
معي ثلاث اربع مرات في المحاضره وبعدين
عشرات المرات خلال الفصل بيستطيع انه
يتقمص شخصيه المبرمج بشكل ضمني انا ما
بحكي له اياها واحد اثنين ثلاثه بينما
الاله بتقدر تحكي له اياها واحد اثنين
ثلاثه ولكن الان بعد ما شافه هو ممكن يقدر
يتخيل حاله ذاك الانسان اللي بيعمل هذا
الاشي الان هذا هذا طبعا مريح جدا بالنسبه
لي لانه انا احس انه بس لاني انسان في
عندي ميزه عن الاله يعني لو الاله عملت
شيء وانا عملت
نفس الشيء بس لاني انا انسان تعطيني ادج
عليه اشي مريح بالنسبه لي انا كانسان ممكن
اجر منه سلسله من الاشياء اللي انا احكي
عنها زي هيك فمثلا انا كانسان عندي شجاعه
الاله ما في عندها اصلا مفهوم الشجاعه
عندي قدره اني انا اخذ رايي واوقف على صف
ما زي الاله بس اقول هناك رايان والراي
والحجته كذا والراي الثاني حجته كذا لا
انا باخذ رايي وبدافع عن هذا الراي
مثلا
عندي الشجاعه اني
وبتحمل المسؤوليه القرار اللي انا ماخذه
الان هذا قرار صحيح ولا مش صحيح مش هذا
اللي على المحك اللي على المحك انه في فرق
كبير لما انك انت تعيش مع شخص بتبنى رايي
وفي شد وجذب حوالين هذا الراي مقارنه بانك
تعرف بوجود رايما فلما انا اجي احكي
للطلاب انه هذه الخاصيه في البرمجه افضل
انك انت تستخدمها مقابل هذه الخاصيه في
البرمجه او لازم انك تبرمج هيك احسن انك
تبرمج زي هيك وابني مساقي كامل بناء على
هذا الراي وهو عارف انه في راي اخر مختلف
تماما الان الشد والجذب اللي بيصير بناء
على تحملي لجانب من الجانبين هو اللي
بيحصل التعلم مش مجرد المعرفه بوجود اراء
مختلفه
بدي اختم بمثال على شيء ازعم انه صعب انه
اله انها تعمله
وهو له علاقه بكون مدرس في الميدان بلاحظ
وبتعامل مع مدرسين بشر كمان عندي في
الميدان
عنا في
اختبارات البرمجه من قيس انه هل الطالب
يستطيع انه يكتب برامج وهل الطالب يستطيع
انه يقرا برامج الان في مدرسين خلال 15
سنه الماضيه لاحظوا من التعامل مع الطلاب
انه في بعض الطلاب عنده القدره انه يفهم
اجزاء البرنامج بس ما بيقدر يشوف الصوره
كامله
فطلعوا بطريقه للقياس عشان نفرق بين هذول
النوعين من الطلاب الطلاب اللي لما يطلعوا
على الكود بيفهم فكرته والثاني لما تطلع
الكود يفهم اجزائه بسموهم اسئله
اكسنسة بعطي الكود وبطلب منه انه يشرح
بالمختصر بالانجليزي ايش هذا البرنامج
بيعمل اذا استخدم كلمات قليله جدا بتعبر
عن الهدف فهو فاهم الفكره اذا استخدمت
تفاصيل طويله وصار يقول لك بيعمل هيك وهيك
وهيك والسطر الاول كذا وكذا فهو مش شايف
الصوره الكامله
الانجلش نتجت عن تفاعل بين دكاتره
وملاحظاتهم انا كمدرس بستخدمها واستخدمها
مده لاحظت انه في كثير من الطلاب عنده
مشكله بالتعبير مش مشكله بالفهم فلما يكون
في عنده
هو بجاوبه غلط مش لانه مش فاهم الصوره
العامه وانما لانه عنده مشكله بالتعبير عن
الصوره العامه
لان هاي الملاحظه جرتني الى سنه كامله
من البحث عن طريقه ممكن افرق فيها بين
الطالب اللي فاهم الصوره العامه واللي
فاهم الاجزاء ما تكون بتعتمد على التعبير
وانما بتعتمد فقط على فهمه للبرنامج هذا
كان خلاله كميه كبيره من السكانز اللي
بعملها للامتحانات الطلاب ولتحليل
وللمناقشه مع دكاتره زائد مقابلات مع
الطلاب اقعد معه واساله خطوه خطوه انت ليش
عملت هيك وليش عملت هيك وليش عملت هيك
عبين ما طلعت بطريقه فعلا انا الان
بستخدمها في الامتحانات
عشان افرق بين هذول النوعين من القدرات في
القراءه يعني انا بدعي انه
هذا لا يمكن الاله انها تعمله لانه
ملاحظتها محصوره بما طلب منها انها
تلاحظوا
وما عندها القدره انها تولد سؤال خارج
نطاق الاسئله اللي يفترض انها تولد فيه
بينما اللي صار معي هون انه انا لاحظت
تولد عندي سؤال جديد حطيت لحالي هدف انه
انا بدي الاقي جواب هذا السؤال
وساعدني في مجموعه ثانيه من الدكاتره اللي
عندهم نفس الملاحظه فطلع معي هذا النوع من
الاسئله
امتحانات ممكن تسالوني عن الامتحانين اللي
كنت بحاول اني انا اكتبهم بدي اوريكم سؤال
كتبته
الساعه اربعه بالليل بعد ما طلع معي سؤال
السؤال كان هذا
انه يرسم ثم افعى مفتوح
الان هذا السؤال كيف طلع طلع نتيجه
الشعيريه هذاك اليوم
قديش انا عندي رغبه انه اطلع بسؤال جديد
مختلف عن اللي كان قبل قديش انا ايش قناتي
من عن كيف لازم نقيس فهم الطلاب ايش قناتي
عن ايش المهم عن صيغه الاسئله الكويسه
قديش بعرف انا عن الطلاب انهم كيف كان
مستواهم باسئله سابقه ايش نوع الامثله
اللي شافوها الدكاتره الثانيه ايش نوع
الاسئله اللي بيحبوها لان هذا الخليط
كلياته انتج سؤال زي هيك فانا برضو كمان
بدعي انه يستحيل على الاله انها تصدر سؤال
مثله الا له كل هاي الاشياء المتراكبه
المعقده كانت عند انسان ولا سؤال مثل هذا
السؤال صار مثال ممكن الاله يتولد زيه
ولكن ابتداء تطلع بزيه
هذا كله كلام مريح وانا مبسوط انه شاعر
انه في اشياء كثيره بس لاني انا انسان
بتعطيني اج على الاله وهيك الاله صعب انها
تبدلني لكن في نفس الوقت
الكلام هذا كلياته اله معنى
وهو انه اذا كنت انا ما بدي استبدل من قبل
الاله
فلازم اركز على الجهه اللي انا احسن من
الاله فيها واللي هي الجانب الانساني اللي
حكيت عنه قبل شوي ولكن اغلب وقتي مش زي
هيك انا اغلب وقتي كمدرس بكتب اسئله
وبحل
بصحح واجبات وبجاوب على اسئله طلاب هاي
كلياتها هي الاشياء السهله اللي الاله
ممكن انها تعملها
الجانب الانساني اللي بيتطلب ملاحظه وبحث
وتجريب وتجسيد مثال وشجاعه واراء وكذا هذا
الجانب كلياته هو الجانب الاصعب في مهنتي
واللي انا هو بياخذ الوقت الاقل مني
فاذا كنت انا ما بدي واستبدل من الاله
فهذا الجانب اللي انا لازم اركز عليه وهذا
الجانب هو الاصعب في مهنتي لذلك اتوقع انه
في المستقبل مهنتي ما راح تكون اسهل راح
تكون اصعب يعطيكم العافيه
[تصفيق]